so it's 1300 GMT and we begin this hour
with breaking news from northern
Pakistan where Army Commandos and
helicopters are trying to rescue eight
people trapped in a cable car 300 meters
above ground
six children and two adults have been
left dangling for hours after one of the
cables snapped this happened when they
were above a remote Mountain Valley in
Khyber paktunkua province Pakistan's
National disaster management agency is
coordinating the rescue effort
Kamala Haider joins us from Islamabad
what can you tell us about what's
happening and what's being done right
now Kamal
well right now helicopters of the Army
Aviation are trying to sling those
Rescuers as close as possible to that
cable car which is now at an angle
because of the two cables that have
snapped uh not snapped but have
basically broken off particularly
possibly from the police which are
supposed to pull that
Carriage now it is important also to
note that it is windy conditions the
helicopters need to be stabled in order
to be able to winch those people down
for the rescue effort however they are
being hampered by high winds and the
fact that there is a another cable which
is about 30 feet above the helicopter
which prevents above that Carriage story
which prevents the helicopter from
coming lower in order to be able to do a
more accurate operation so indeed a
delicate dangerous operation and now the
we are hearing that the head of the
Commando unit this is the elite
Pakistani special Commando unit they are
commanding officer is on site they're
also talking of possibly carrying on
into the night it will be dark within
the next one hour here in Pakistan that
of course could pose a serious problem
also the fact that whether in these
areas can change rapidly so all
everybody here will be praying that
everything goes smoothly but indeed a
dangerous operation indeed in trying to
rescue these children who are stuck on
that Carriage it come out to I want to
bounce off a point that you just made
it's 6 p.m right now in khyberpaktunque
so the Sun is going to set and very soon
they're going to have to be doing this
in the dark is that possible has there
been any communication on what can
happen once there's no more light
well that is going to be the biggest
challenge because uh like I said
helicopter operations are not allowed
after dark in this mountainous region
this is a a treacherous terrain there
are mountains on both sides uh the cable
car is dangling over a river and a
forest down below so that of course is
going to add to the complications
however there will be one last minute
attempt before dark uh how that goes
because as I mentioned to you earlier
the rescue is being hampered by winds
which pick up in that narrow Valley and
also the fact that the weather can
change and of course not to mention as
you mentioned yourself once it's dark it
will be very challenging they will need
special lights perhaps perhaps even
night vision equipment in order to carry
on this rescue effort and come on Hider
their reporting from Islamabad if there
are any major developments do let us
know you'll keep a surprise thank you
very much Kamal and so Kamal did mention
the weather is also a factor here so
let's bring in weather presenter Jeff
Harrington who's joined us in the studio
what can you tell us about whether
conditions at that precise location Jeff
well you know winds are the big factor
here Cyril so I was just checking Gus
right now 25 to 35 kilometers per hour
so a wind like that is enough to sway
the cable car now we know this is about
300 meters above the ground right so
undoubtedly for those eight people
trapped inside that cable car a little
bit of a sway must be terrifying so
winds really really the big factor here
now that's the bad news the good news is
the monsoon rains across Pakistan have
actually backed off could you imagine
these pictures that we're looking at
right now if that was an intense
rainstorm and rescue crews were up
against that so that is the one thing
working on their side that said there is
the risk of thunderstorms in this area
tomorrow and anytime there's
thunderstorms the winds can pick up
without much notice and when we talk
about wingas these these are bursts of
wind it doesn't mean it's sustained
right through so every now and then
you'll get a gust of about 30 kilometers
per hour again enough to sway that cable
car come on is that something we're
going to see what over the next few
hours yes it's going to persist
absolutely and Kamal also mentioned that
this is a mountainous area so conditions
can really rapidly change this is
something that we have to keep an eye on
so the wind is the bad news right now
but the good news is at least the
conditions are calm there's no rain in
the area at this moment okay that's all
really valuable information at this
point Jeff Harrington thank you so much
for joining us you're welcome